[Music]
hello and welcome to episode number 75
of the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I am Princess campoy and I'm
here with my colleague mark Mandel hey
Mark how are you doing
I'm very well Frances how are you doing
very good very excited to have the
engineering director nonetheless of a
gold container engine yeah we're gonna
have Han Goldberg joining us she is
super super cool super super smart and
very passionate about containers and
open source I love how effortlessly you
pronounce the name
years a'practice yeah yeah and she's
gonna be telling us a little bit about
kubernetes itself but also like what is
the difference between kubernetes
container engine about the community and
it's it's a very interesting interview
I've really loved learned a lot from it
and then after that we have a question
of the week that comes from slack it
does come from slack one of the users
I'm going to mispronounce this it's like
a handle sha hello Ida drawer it's words
we're talking about the cloud builder
and how to access external repositories
if you want to access them within your
build steps interesting will have also
to mention real quick what cloud builder
is because I don't think we've mentioned
it before so we should do it so well
we'll do that and but before that we
have our cool things of the week as
usual and we have two of them you are
the one I other one so I'm gonna let you
go first with the one about apparently
someone complained that this had not
been yet yeah I don't think of the we
had a minute cool thing is we've got to
the point where people are like you
didn't mention this thing we're now mad
yeah I love it
yeah so if you haven't looked at the
location section of Google cloud
platform and having a look at all the
regions we have you may not have noticed
that there is a new Singapore region
that is now available yeah so you'll
find that there are two zones in that
region
Asia Asia Southeast 1a and Asia
Southeast 1b they have lovely Intel Xeon
processors and 64 quart machine types as
well as local SSDs
sitting there waiting for you to take
advantage of them
yep it is it is pretty awesome if you
are any
around there you should be also able to
see a TC ping
just being a little bit faster if you're
closer to one of those data centers so
yeah like from here in San Francisco a
little bit far away it's actually
probably the farthest away I'm getting
174 milliseconds yeah that is the
farthest away we are it does probably
our father's data center from San
Francisco right now so you know kind of
make sense but if you're there it's way
closer that makes sense so yeah check it
out and I think that not all the
services are available yet but you can
find that information on the
documentation page that we will link
from the show notes exactly cool and so
what did you have as a cool thing a
great France ask the second cool thing
of the week is actually a tweet that I
saw from projected Joshy and I checked
who she was and turns out she's a
product manager for Google cloud
platform and she was talking about the
fact that there's a new thing supported
by HTTP load balancers which is
WebSockets WebSockets yay it is a nice
PMSing because if I remember correctly
we actually talked about how to deal
with this we did long ago and you know
it was not the easiest or NASA's of the
experiences so it is it is awesome then
now is fixed so if you want to use
WebSockets over HTTP load balancer which
is the global load balancer you can just
do it it is it is very simple we have as
always a link to the commutation from
the show notes and and I don't think
this much to say other than it just
works yeah it looks really really cool
it is worth noting that if you have
configured client IP or generated code
session affinity for your load balancers
then your WebSocket connections from a
client and sent to the same back-end
instance so it reflects the sticky
sessions yeah which is important for
WebSockets um but otherwise yeah it
looks like it's just really good to go
yeah it's great so so that's awesome I'm
very happy about it and also I didn't
know about projector joshi so I searched
on Google and I saw that she also talked
about TCP next she seems really cool so
if you're listening to this projector
you're very very very invited to come
and join the podcast and talk about a
little bit networking and all the
cool things in Google app I thought
definitely definitely awesome well why
don't we go have a chat with hen and
talk to her all about gke
and kubernetes sounds good let's do that
so it's another today for me to welcome
the engineering director of gke
nonetheless a hen goldberg how are you
doing great i'm very happy to be here
thank you Amy yeah very happy like we
met a party right after cloud next and
since then I really really wanted you to
come to the podcast and tell us a little
bit about how it is to be working at gke
but before you start talking about gke
and all the details of kubernetes and
all that cool stuff why don't you tell
us a little bit about who you are what
you do at Google so I'm an engineering
manager
that means that I'm passionate about
building teams and helping building
teams to be productive and building
products that customers and users like
and while I've always been very drawn to
infrastructure I was able to bring that
passion to users into the infrastructure
world and at Google I'm doing my dream
job open source means building huge team
and impacting debt helping making sure
that the community is productive and a
happy community and we have a great
product SDK so I'm having a great time
all right cool um so why don't we start
with we start with an easy question so
what is gke what is Google container
engine a good container engine is a
platform that helps you manage your
containerized applications the same as
Google does we and Google been managing
a application within containers like
Gmail and maps for over 12 years now and
with GK were able to provide the same
service and offer link to Google cloud
platform users this means that when you
are choosing gke you can really focus on
developing your application and giclee
allows you to quickly deploy your
application
and make it available to users as a
service and we are responsible for all
the product ization of your service and
the differentiation is it's an amazing
technology of kubernetes which is the
heart of gke
together with Google cloud platform in
general which means all the goodness of
Google Network and storage and machine
learning it is available and on top of
everything I think what's very unique
for Google and we are known for is our
operational excellence site reliability
engineers and the practices that we have
built throughout the years are being
implemented for users through G key so
not that long ago we had an amazing
episode we had the chance to have Jen
Twi'leks talking about Borg and
kubernetes but for those that have not
listened to any of our kubernetes
episodes could you tell us a little bit
about like why is kubernetes a thing
like what is what is cool about it
everything of course as I said before
kubernetes is the heart of Google
container engine it's an open source
platform for automating deployment
scaling and operations of containerized
applications across clusters with
kubernetes you're able once you are
familiar with containers and you have a
microservice applications you are able
to deploy your applications quickly in a
predictable way and scale on the fly
which means that it's very easy to meet
a changing demand and together with
kubernetes cool so then like what's the
difference or possibly the relationship
between kubernetes and container engine
how does that work the first thing is
that kubernetes is open source and it
runs anywhere this is also the the main
differentiation between bog or internal
container centric infrastructure and
kubernetes for the team that founded
kubernetes it was very important to make
it open source because we understand it
cloud today while we see that it's a
very popular trend still most of the
workloads are not running in cloud but
they're running on premise so we know
that if people want to move to
containers
and they want to be agile and too
quickly to deploy they're actually
looking to do it not in the cloud but in
other environments so the team really
wanted to do to make something open so
that would be easily adopted so that's
one and the second thing is that by him
making it open source we are building a
very rich ecosystem around it so you
have many other tools that are bridging
the gap if it's from developer
experience security storage and network
and more so then that means that
basically I can get kubernetes and run
it basically anywhere and every single
time and say you can run kubernetes
everywhere it comes to my mind the demo
that ray sagg did where he runs
kubernetes on a cluster of raspberry
PI's so that one on top of each other
which is pretty cool
so you can run it virtually anywhere but
we offer a way to run it on GK Google
container engine what is the benefit of
running it on Google container engine
rather than just installing it on your
own cluster for so just being off a new
cluster in kubernetes is not something
how to do okay we actually invested a
lot in making it easy with to like like
you buy DM and we even emphasize it
would be easy and a consistent way
across different platforms wherever you
run it the value of gke or container
engine is by the operating of what
happened next
so you spin off your cluster this is
great then even use that deploy your
application on that cluster how do you
keep the cluster updated how do you get
the most recent kubernetes versions
Google dinner engine is there is-where
1.6 is already available we are always
the first one to make innovation of
kubernetes available within the
kubernetes community and we are doing it
without compromising quality so when we
make it available on gke we have tested
it and we make sure that it will work
well for customers we are upgrading
automatically both the master the
control plane of the cluster and the
nodes and we provide you out-of-the-box
the integration to everything that you
need to actually selves customers for
your application so integration with
network and load balancing and storage
and just solving all the infrastructure
for you what I often hear from
developers is two things
GK is the best and easiest way to try
out kubernetes because it's so easy to
spin off a cluster but the more
important thing it's the easiest and
fastest way to make your application
product iced so if you are a start-up
for example and you want to quickly set
up something and maybe serve in multi
regions GK and GCPs
is a very easy way to go so you
mentioned updates and I'm curious about
that because since kubernetes is built
for failure for reliance resilience
against failure I'm assuming that that
might help with update process for
savior's but how does it work do I even
care when the update happens from 1.5 to
one that takes for instance so for
though this is from some of our secret
sauce oh how we do it in Jake
interesting and no you shouldn't care
and of course we make sure that we will
not introduce risks there is a way if
someone wants to opt out but we think
abilities we are making sure that we are
a backhoe compatible we can upgrade for
you and the master and usually you don't
know and you don't kill the machines
themselves that are part of the
equivalence class cells are more tricky
this is area where some Zuppa fail to
opt out of those capabilities especially
if they have in their application design
some constraints that we cannot foresee
but overall we are making the upgrade
while we mitigate the risk making sure
your application continues the serve as
you would expect that's cool cool and
you talked about it a little bit but I'd
love to hear some more detail like so
gke was too integrated more with GCP
like there are certain things out of the
box that are available can you talk a
bit about the sort of features and tools
that are directly integrated into the
hosted kubernetes solution that we run I
think that the most thing to highlight
is the infrastructure for example our
VMs powered by a Google compute engine
you can have flexible machines you can
decide exactly what types of machines
you will have Adele the fastest to start
up and this is a very unique to GCP and
network of course works out of the box
we allow you to integrate into the IAM
capabilities of the rest of GCP and also
what we likely see more and more is how
Jiki customers are leveraging the
machine learning services available on
GCP so those are just few examples of
the power of gke together with GCP cool
so let's talk a little bit about DK we
just had the 1.6 version of a cup of
kubernetes released and you mentioned
that is already available on GK
what is what is the coolest thing in
your opinion what is your favorite
feature of all the things that are new
I'm excited usually about the big things
that we are trying to do and then there
are multiple features that allow us to
move forward Aparna in her keynote cube
corn in Berlin when we announced 1.6 it
was talking about how kubernetes is
moving forward in supporting multi
workloads and multi users at scale and
to me that's the exciting part that I I
look forward this year with kubernetes
when you are running your applications
at scale within a cluster this is where
it becomes the most efficient this is
where it's exciting this is where you
need to invest less in operating the
cluster itself so there are two examples
of features that are really helping us
move forward that so one is supporting
5,000 nodes I hope a single cluster this
is also available on GCP that is huge
it's good but it's not just about the
right size it's not all that matters we
have for example introduced a a better a
what we call our bug role-based access
control which gives you more granularity
of permissions within a cluster so if
before it was harder to have multiple
teams for example work within a cluster
it meant that you were forced to have
multiple clusters now that's no longer
the case
and I think that's the most exciting
basically the whole idea here is that
rather than having like a tostada
you have like maybe three clusters for
three different teams working together
now you have one cluster that might be a
little bit bigger but now you have all
the things running together yes that is
really cool
yes and just to make sure that we don't
confuse anyone we still recommend the
separating development environment from
production environment that's a very
good point yeah but other than that yes
definitely have any multiple teams or
multiple services even in production
serving from the same cluster so um just
from an outside perspective or even from
an inside perspective it seems like the
community surrounding kubernetes is just
growing by leaps and bounds even in the
last six months to a year I do have any
involvement in that yes I think this is
this is what was most exciting for me in
this role is helping to build this
community kubernetes as an open-source
project is very unique by a for the
reason that we encourage and we want to
have more contribution so we were
actively working on increasing the
percentage of Google contribution into
kubernetes when we started Googlers
contributed 76% of the commits and right
now it's in the low 40s
mmm nice and it's not like my team is
not growing we grow faster we're still
hiring if anyone is interested it is
just that we make sure that the
community grow even faster than we do
and and that's important for us we found
it a product or technology like
kubernetes will not be successful
without it like let's take the promise
of runs anywhere
for that we need users to actually run
it anywhere we know we don't do it we
know that we are experienced with our
gke users and what we know from Google
but we have Red Hat for example or
coalesce they are running on premise
kubernetes and managing it their
feedback is very important for the
community we see other that are helping
with developer experience and
simplification and a network and
security just having all of those
expertise together and getting that
feedback really fast is what makes
kubernetes so special
in my mind so I guess we've been talking
around the this topic for basically the
whole time but like we keep on talking
about community and and I guess that the
fact that it is open source helps with
community but not only like could you
tell us a little bit about why's
kubernetes open source to start with so
first of all you know is engineering
managers open generally as engineers I
think it's very hard to compete with
technologies that are not open sourced I
mean there is a limit of how many people
a single company can put into a single
product and I think it is something that
is very clear with kubernetes the amount
of investment right now
it was calculates about 400 engineering
years already
well no that's huge I don't have such a
big team to support it I mean for me as
an engineering manager and also the team
we think that the innovation pace is
unmatchable when choosing a open source
and also for Google specifically I think
open metals open source matters but it
matters more in cloud I will talk about
the portability aspect which is very
important we keep saying to our
customers we want you to have a choice
so you have the freedom to come to
Google cloud platform but also have the
freedom to live we want you to stay
because this is the best cloud for you
obviously
we're biased but you know people can
live and they choose to stay hey
openness is not just about choosing the
platform but also the flexibility which
tools to use there are so many CICE
tools and that by the way keeps changing
and there will be always new
technologies so by making it open-source
we know that new technologies will
continue to be introduced into
kubernetes and support it because it's
open source because it's easy to do it
and when building a community and
kubernetes we invest probably half of
our time in building kubernetes as a
technology and half of the time around
building the community and making it
easy to develop on top of kubernetes so
if I'm now a startup that wants to
integrate into kubernetes or just a
vendor or even an enter
price customer I think this is a reason
why day like open source you can tailor
it to your own need and we invest a lot
in extensibility we care about
fragmentation and in general making sure
that the success of of kubernetes is
sustainable great so since you're
talking about the fact that there's a
very big interest on people building on
top of fuga Nettie's and you know we've
actually interviewed at helm
we haven't appeared a bunch of different
people building stuff like fish and also
some communities a bunch of different
projects that run on kubernetes which is
amazing so what is what is the coolest
or the most interesting one that you
have seen baby I wouldn't say the the
most interesting but I can say something
that I was passionate about and let's go
with that investing more in is
definitely helm kubernetes started with
a very infrastructure oriented people
many ops people and last year our main
focus was making sure it's easy for
developers to start using kubernetes and
I don't think we're done yet but but
with helm I think it's amazing the
amount of charts that we have that
support the multiple workloads different
type of workloads and we make sure that
everything that we produce and buy we we
say we because it's a community effort
of course led by desse team to make sure
that everything is tested and that when
released new releases we want to make
sure that things are still working as
expected
and so that's one thing that I'm really
excited about from within the kubernetes
community but that's just one example
that's awesome since you're mentioning
ideas they were on the news not that
long ago because they joining Microsoft
why is your view on all of this what do
you think first of all I think this is
exciting for the kubernetes community
because this is just evidence to show
how companies realize the value of
kubernetes and it's also validates our
belief that developers want openness and
flexibility in the cloud and more
specifically for the asset dance our
friends
and very important members of the member
of the community of kubernetes and i'm
really happy for them and i hope that
with this acquisition they can do more
for kubernetes awesome well we're kind
of running out of time but is there
anything else that you like to add any
topic that we've forgotten or anything
else that you just like to mention yes I
think that we haven't touched it we
talked about the technology and openness
but one thing that I am passionate about
definitely is an engineering manager is
about building the right culture and I
think that the right recipe to build a
strong team is having a very strong
culture and set of values that's the
thing I like the most about kubernetes
it's about openness and appreciating
feedback inclusiveness and diversity
from the moment I joined kubernetes
community I felt comfortable and
respected and I I hope everybody else
feels like that and I would welcome
everybody to join us yes it's a segue
from there if people want to get
involved with the kubernetes community
where should they go that's a good
question kubernetes can be very
overwhelming with the size of it and we
have a concept which we call the special
interest groups there are smaller groups
within the community of people working
together on an area they are passionate
about there is - about 25 of these and
we can add in the notes exactly linked
to that I think the best way is just to
choose an area you care about and join
one of these special interest groups
then you will know the people by name
you can see the faces on GVC or resume
or whatever meeting - we'll be using
them and that would probably be the
easiest one I can highlight one specific
we have a contributes perience a special
interest group which is focusing on the
contributor experience so even if you
know nothing about Cooper that is but
you know something about developer
experience and open source that will be
the easiest way to get involved that's
great we'll have a bunch of links from
the show notes to point to of those
special interest groups and also we'll
have
a bunch of links to different talks from
cube come I know that your keynote was
really good so if people are interested
in learning more I think it's a very
good place to go to excellent well and
thank you so much for joining us every
week right to have you on the podcast
thank you very much thanks again to fan
for joining us it was really great to
have a chat with her and hear about her
opinions and her perspective on
container engine and kubernetes yeah and
just talking to her cause she's awesome
yep now we're going for our question of
the week and as we said is a question of
the week coming from slack from the
username sha underscore hello Aida or
something like that so the question is
if I want to access a private repo from
container builder how do I do it cool so
this just depends so yeah before we
start answering the question we should
mention what are those things like what
is a container builder yep and what is a
what is a private repo so container
builder container builder is essentially
like an automated system for building
containers on-site Google platform it
can be fired manually so you can
actually run it locally to basically use
the cloud to build containers in the
cloud but you can also have it run on
say when a git repo gets pushed to or
something like that and then have it
trigger automatically you can have
multiple build steps and can do just
more than just building a simple
container so it's a pretty nice little
piece of foundation work for building
like continuous integration and
continuous delivery systems yeah what I
like about it is the fact that it allows
you to build containers very easily and
you can run it directly from G clubs
like G cloud container build submit
something you don't need to install
docker in your mission if you don't have
it that's fine you can still build your
containers and push it to the Container
repository and will contain a registry
actually and then access it from there
so that that's pretty awesome so to do
that a container builder accesses repos
it downloads code from places and when
it's a public repo no matter where it is
well it's public so you can access it
yeah but what if it's private ok so
you're working probably on some sort of
commercial application you don't want it
to be exposed to the outside world
there's a couple of options here so
cloud platform does allow you to have
source repositories they are private
repositories private git repositories
that come with Google cloud platform and
they're pretty awesome I use them all
the time I use them too they're really
super simple so if you're running Google
Cloud builder in the same project as the
source repository that you have your
code in then there's not going problem
they should be able to grab that code
pull it down do what it needs to do
sweet it's perfect if you have your
source repository in a different project
yeah you will need to configure some
permissions on that repository so that
your external repository can then access
it so basically give that that that
builder project access to that source
repository so we can do that makes sense
if you have something like a private git
repo on sale at github then we're going
to need to get some SSH keys so how do
you do that how do we do that so in the
future hopefully this should be a whole
lot easier and they'll be nice steps the
solution that we talked about having now
basically is store those keys in a
private Google Cloud Storage bucket so
we're kind of somewhere so that the
outside world can't get to them but that
project can and then within your build
step just download those keys from that
good storage bucket put them in there in
the appropriate space probably like an
SSH folder and then you'll be able to
access your git repository pretty much
exactly as you would do normally nice I
wonder if it could be also doable from
like if you saw it and made a data
server or something like that but it's
probably easier to do it on Google Cloud
Storage you can even like that's
actually something that people do not
realize you can just drag and drop files
from your desktop to the bucket which is
a pretty amazing it's pretty easy and
you know then you've got also a lot of
control because you have all the ACLs
like the access control lists and that
kind of stuff as well that's a very good
reason to that way up yeah so container
builder pretty flexible you can do a lot
with it it's actually really really cool
yeah it is definitely worth trying I'm
gonna be playing with it soon because
there's the other thing the docker build
that is multi-step and have you heard
about it
I have not it allows you to do things
like you know when you want to build
something and you want to put all your
tooling and compilers and stuff and then
you want to generate a binary and you
want that binary to be in the smallest
container image possible oh yeah so it
allows you to do exactly that that's
similar to what I do by hand but
exactly let's make files I know it might
may sound a little bit sad for you to
have less make fast actually a good
thing so yeah I'm gonna be playing with
that and I'm pretty sure that a
container builder is a very nice way to
do that okay cool I think yeah I think
we're gonna have to look at that a
little bit later yep
what are you up to what are you doing
were you going anything interesting on
the calendar so by the time this episode
comes out I'll be already in New York
and I had presented already last Monday
so may 1st the Google developer group
New York City talking about endpoints
with our dear friend Brett he will be
talking about Club functions and after
that I'll be back right on time for
Google i/o because I will not be going
to Google i/o but May 15th we will be
hosting go for fest San Francisco which
is a very cool event hosted here in the
San Francisco well in the launch pad
which is by the San Francisco office mhm
lots of cool talks about go community
etc what about you cool so the week that
this podcast comes out of helping host
the extra life and play crafting game
jam will be raising money for kids in
hospital then I don't go anywhere for a
week which is really nice crazy and then
the week after that I go to Sweden to
Nordic game conference where I'm off to
talk about kubernetes and game servers
and all the good stuff there nice and
right after that it will be right after
Google i/o so there will be some fresh
announcements probably over something we
should do some a special special episode
or something something like that sounds
like a reasonable thing to do we'll see
excellent well Francis thank you again
for joining me for yet another episode
of the podcast thank you Mark and thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
[Music]